This lecture is about the probabilistic
topic models for topic mining and
analysis.
In this lecture we're going to continue
talking about the top mining and analysis.
We're going to introduce probabilistic
topic models.
So this is a slide that you have seen
earlier where we discussed the problems
with using a term as a topic.
So to solve these problems intuitively
we need to use more words to describe
the topic and this would address the
problem of lack of expressive power.
When we have more words that we can use
to describe the topic, we can
describe complicated topics, to address
the second problem, we need to
introduce weights of words.
This would allow you to distinguish
subtle differences in topics and to
introduce semantically related words in
the fuzzy manner.
Finally, to solve the problem of word
ambiguity, we need to split an
ambiguous word so that we can
disambiguate its topic.
It turns out that all these can be
done by using a probabilistic topic
model, and that's why we're going to
spend a lot of lectures to talk about
this topic.
So the basic idea here is improved
representation of topic as a word
distribution.
So what you see now is the old
representation, where we represent each
topic with just one word or one term or
one phrase.
But now we're going to use a word
distribution to describe the topic.
So here you see that for sports, we're
going to use a word distribution over
theoretical speaking
all the words in our vocabulary.
So for example, the high probability
words here are sports, game, basketball,
football, play, star, etc.
These are sports-related terms and of
course it would also give a non zero
probability to some other words like
"travel" which might be related to
sports.
But in general not so much related to
the topic.
In general, we can imagine a non zero
probability for all the words and some
words that are not relevant would have
very very small probabilities and these
probabilities will sum to one.
So that it forms a distribution of all
the words.
Now intuitively, this distribution
represents a topic in that if we sample
words from the distribution, we tend to
see words that already do sports.
You can also see it as a very special
case if the probability mass is
concentrated entire of just one word.
Let's sports, and this basically
degenerates to the simple
representation of topic with just one
word.
But as a distribution, this topic
representation can in general involve
many words to describe the topic and
can model subtle differences in
semantics of the topic.
Similarly, we can model travel and
science with their respective
distributions.
So in the distribution for travel we
see top words like "attraction, trip,
flight, hotel etc."
Whereas in science, we see "scientist,
spaceship, telescope or genomics" and new
science-related terms, now, that
doesn't mean sports-related terms
necessary have zero probabilities
for science in general, we can imagine
all these words.
We have non zero probabilities, it's
just that for a particular topic of
some words we have very very small
probabilities.
Now you can also see there are some
words that are shared by these topics.
Well, when I say shared, that just means
even with some probability threshold
you can still see one word to occur in
multiple topics.
In this case I marked them in black so
you can see "travel",
for example, occured in all the three
topics here, but with different
probabilities.
It has the highest probability for the
travel topic 0.05.
But with much smaller probabilities for
sports and science, which makes sense.
And similarly you can see "star" also
occurred in sports and science with
reasonably high probabilities, because
they might be actually related to the
two topics.
So with this representation it
addresses the three problems that
mentioned earlier.
First, it now uses multiple words that
describe topic, so it allows us to
describe fairly complicated topics.
Second, it assigns weights to terms, so
now we can model several differences of
semantics and you can bring in related words
together to model topic. Third,
because we have probabilities for the
same word in different topics.
We can disambiguate the sense of word
in the text to decode its underlying
topic, so we address all these three
problems with this new way of
representing a topic.
So now, of course, our problem
definition has been refined just
slightly.
The slide is very similar to what you
have seen before, except that we have
added refinement for
what the topic is.
So now each topic is word
distribution.
And for each word distribution, we know
that all the probabilities should
sum to one over all the words in the
vocabulary.
So you see a constraint here and we
still have another constraint on the
topic coverage, namely pis.
So all the pis of ij's must sum to one
for the same document.
So how do we solve this problem?
Well, let's look at this problem as a
computation problem now.
So we clearly specify the input and
output as illustrated here on this
side.
The input, of course is our text data
C is the collection, but we also
generally assume we know the number of
topics K or we hypothesize a number and
then try to mine K topics, even though
we don't know the exact topics that
exist in the collection and these
vocabulary set.
As a set of words that determines what
units would be treated as
the basic units for analysis.
In most cases, we use words as the
basis.
For analysis, and that means each word
is a unit.
Now the output would consist of as first
a set of topics represented by Theta
i's
Each theta_i is a word distribution.
And
We also want to know the coverage of topics
in each document so that that's the
same pi_ij's that we have seen before.
So given a set of text data, we would
like to compute all these distributions
and all these coverages as you have
seen on this slide.
Now of course, there may be many
different ways of solving this problem.
Indeed, you can write a heuristic
program to solve this problem, but here
we're going to introduce a general way of
solving this problem called
generative model, and this is in fact
very general idea, and it's a
principle way of using statistical
modeling to solve text mining problems,
and here I dim the picture that you
have seen before in order to show the
generation process.
So the idea of this approach is
actually to 1st design a model for our
data.
So we design a probabilistic model to
model how the data are generated.
Of course this is based on our
assumption.
The actual data aren't necessary generated
this way, so that would give us a
probability distribution of the data
that you are seeing on this slide given
a particular model and parameters that
are denoted by Lambda.
So this capital lambda actually consists
of all the parameters that we're
interested in. And these parameters
in general, will control the behavior of
the probabilistic model, meaning that
if you set these parameters for
different values,
it will give some data points
higher probabilities than others.
Now in this case, of course, for our
tax mining problem, or more precisely
topic mining problem, we have the
following parameters.
First, we have theta_i's
Each is a word distribution and then we
have a set of pi's for each document.
And since we have N documents so we
have N sets of pis.
And each set of the pi values
will sum to one.
So this is to say that we first pretend
we already have these word
distributions and coverage numbers, and
then we're going to see how we can
generate data by using such
distributions.
So how do we model the data in this
way?
And we assume that data are actually
samples drawn from such a model that
depends on these parameters.
Now one interesting question here is to
think about how many parameters are
there in total.
Now obviously we can already see N * K
parameters for pi's.
We also see K theta_i's, but each theta_i is
actually a set of probability values.
Right? It's a distribution over words.
So I leave this as exercise for you to
figure out exactly how many parameters
there are here.
Now, once we set up with a model, then
we can fit the model to our data,
meaning that we can estimate the
parameters or infer the parameters
based on the data.
In other words, we would like to adjust
these parameter values until we give
our data set the maximum probability.
I just say that depending on the
parameter values, some data points will
have higher probabilities than others.
What we're interested in here is what
parameter values will give our data set
the highest probability.
So I also illustrate the problem with
the picture that you see here. On the X
axis,
I just illustrate the Lambda, the
parameters as one dimensional variable.
It's oversimplification obviously, but
it suffices is to show the idea and the
Y axis shows the probability of the
data
observe. This probability obviously
depends on the setting of Lambda, so
that's why it varies as you change the
value of Lambda.
What we're interested in here is
to find the Lambda star that would
maximize the probability of the
observed data.
So this would be then our estimate of
the parameters and these parameters
note that are precisely what we hope to
discover from text data, so would treat
these parameters as actually the
outcome or the output of the data
mining algorithm.
So this is a general idea of using a
generative model for text mining.
First, we design a model with some
parameters that we are interested in,
and then we model the data.
We adjust the parameters to fit the
data as well as we can.
After we have fitted data then we will
recover some parameter values will get
this specific parameter values and
those would be the output of the
algorithm and we treat those as
actually the discovered knowledge from
text data.
By varying the model, of course we can
discover different knowledge.
So to summarize, we introduced a new
way of representing a topic, namely
represented as word distribution, and
this has advantage of using multiple
words to describe a complicated topic.
It also allows us to assign weights on
words so we can model subtle
variations of semantics.
We talked about the task of topic
mining and analysis when we define a topic
as a distribution, so the input is a
collection of text articles.
The number of topics and vocabulary set
and the output is a set of topics.
Each is word distribution.
And also the coverage of all the topics
in each document and these are formally
represented by theta_i's and pi_i's and we
have two constraints here
for these parameters. The first is the
constraint on the word distributions.
In each world distribution, the
probabilities on all the words must sum
to one over all the words in the
vocabulary.
The second constraint is on the topic
coverage in each document.
A document is not allowed to cover
a topic outside the set of topics that
we are discovering.
So the coverage of each of these K
topics would sum to one for a document.
We also introduce the general idea of
using a generative model for text mining
and the idea here is to first design a
model to model the generation of data.
We simply assume that they are
generated this way and inside the
model, we embed some parameters that
were interested in denoted by Lambda.
And then we can infer the most likely
parameter values lambda star given
a particular data set, and we can then
take the Lambda star as knowledge
discovered from the text for our
problem, and we can adjust the design
of the model and parameters with this
discover various kinds of knowledge
from text.
As you will see later
in the other lectures.